en même temps je crois pas à la
vaccination obligatoire pour ce vaccin
parce que d'abord il faut être toujours
très honnête et très transparent on ne
sait pas tout sur ce vaccin comme on ne
sait pas tout sur le virus en même temps
pour les personnels soignants et non
soignants des hôpitaux des cliniques des
maisons de retraite des établissements
pour personnes en situation de handicap
pour tous les professionnels ou
bénévoles qui travaillent au contact des
personnes âgées ou fragiles y compris à
domicile
la vaccination sera rendue obligatoire
sans attendre en même temps je ne
rendrai pas la vaccination obligatoire
en même temps gouvernement a fait savoir
aussi son intention de ne pas recourir
aux passeports sanitaires en même temps
c'est ça le pas salutaire c'est pas du
tout quelque chose qui vise à exclure en
même temps dès le 21 juillet
le pass sanitaire sera étendue aux lieux
de loisirs et de culture
concrètement pour tous nos compatriotes
de plus de 12 ans il faudra pour accéder
à un spectacle à parc d'attractions un
concert ou un festival avoir été
vaccinée en même temps je suis contre le
pas salutaire dans le resto je suis
contre le pas salutaire pour mais ces
gamins à l'école j'ai fait contre tout
ça non on n'est pas en train d'installer
un système de tri ou de sélection des
genres en fonction d'un statut sanitaire
en même temps on va pas demander aux
français emballent sanitaires pour aller
boire un café en bas de chez soi a
fortiori en terrasse en même temps c'est
que je considère que le jour où on
pourra rouvrir des lieux pour le public
qui doivent être rouverts pour tous je
ne considère pas à titre personnel qu'on
puisse dire un français qui était
vacciné il peut aller manger au
restaurant qui ne l'est pas
si nos tarifs ne puisse pas y aller en
même temps à partir du début du mois
d'août
et cela parce qu'ils nous font faire
d'abord voté un texte de loi le
promulguer à partir du début du mois
d'août donc le pass sanitaire
s'appliquera dans les cafés les
restaurants les centres commerciaux
ainsi que dans les hôpitaux les maisons
de retraite établissements médicaux
sociaux mais aussi dans les avions
trains et cars pour les longs trajets là
encore seuls les vacciner pourront
accéder à ces lieux en même temps quand
je dis pas sanitaire c'est que ça ne
peut pas être soumis au vaccin
parce que si on arrive à un moment de
printemps à rouvrir certains de ces
lieux
nous ne saurions conditionné leur accès
à une vaccination alors même que nous
n'aurions même pas ouvert la vaccination
aux plus jeunes d'entre nous serait
invraisemblable
donc faut pas le lier au vaccin c'est
plus complexe que ça c'est un ensemble
en même temps en même temps